um
right good evening everybody welcome to
the development committee
19th of november 2020
um apologies for absence they've been
received from
from councillor yano um
there are no substitute members
attending item two
item three are non-members attending
i've seen councillor gooding
councillor mcpherson and councillor
steptoe
thank you um item four is meeting of the
minute
um minutes of the meeting found on the
22nd of october 2020
they happy for me to sign those as a
correct and accurate record
rude yeah thank you i see no
resistance to that thank you item five
is to receive declarations of interest
looking around the screen unusually we
have
none tonight excellent right item six
his land to the east of the rugby club
aviation
way rochford and katie oh cancer stepped
on your hands up yes chairman just to
declare an interest as uh county
councillor for the uh
for the area of both applications okay
thank you
so yes um item six land to the east of
the rugby club
aviation way rochford katie rogers is
going to
present to us on this one please thank
you katie
thank you i'm just going to share my
screen with you
sonia it says host has disabled host
disabled participant screen sharing
thank you
okay so hopefully members on you can see
a location plan on screen for this
application
so this application relates to a wider
site which is edge blue
on the plan on the screen this was
granted outline planning permission for
a business park in 2016.
the wider site runs adjacent to cherry
orchard um way to the west
um and it butts the um aviation business
park to the south
this application relates to the area
edge red towards the central part of the
site
the site would have bought part of the
strategic green space
along the northern boundary and along
the western boundary
i'll take you to the layout plan
the application proposes four buildings
two elongated larger buildings so one
running adjacent to the western boundary
one running along the northern boundary
and then two smaller buildings
one here where the cursor is and another
here
two vehicle accesses are proposed off
the main spine road one on this
one on the eastern side of the site
and one to the southern boundary
the buildings would have frontages
facing inwards towards the center of the
site in this area here
and entrances for pedestrians and
vehicles to unload within the units
um to the front elevations
parking will be provided to the front of
each unit and cycle and refuse stores
would also be provided dotted around the
site so there's one where my cursor
is here another park refusing cycle
store here
and again in front of these parts here
and here
so on screen now is the proposed
landscaping plan
soft landscaping will be provided in the
southeastern area of the site so where
my cursor is here
with grasp planting in the central area
around which trees and hedge planting
would be provided
the hedging would in time shield the
proposed 2.5 meter
security boundary fence which would run
along where my cursor is indicating here
in this corner of the site this boundary
fence would also run
um around the entire perimeter of the
site so
all around the edge essentially and
there would be a gated access point here
across
this circular access and just just north
of the southern boundary
in the course of the application more
robust tree planting has been proposed
with a greater number of semi-mature
trees
now proposed to give a greater instant
impact
in total some 66 new trees will be
provided
including some now between the parking
areas so if you can see where my cursive
is indicating here
um so there'll be a hedge and planting
to break up this what would otherwise be
quite an expansive sort of hard surface
um area here and then there's again here
and here within the um sort of
built up area of the site a slight
amendment to the proposed conditions
two and four is therefore recommended to
ensure that this additional
landscaping is delivered as this is not
shown on the original
originally provided site layout plan
um the bins and cycle stores that i
referred to
um just pointing out in the layout and
would be fenced
with galvanized um galvanized steel
structure
um so the cycle store being this um sort
of open
area whereas the bins would be um
shielded from view
with this galvanized steel
if i take you to the elevation
the plan on screen shows the elevations
to one of the proposed buildings
um but all the others would be of the
same appearance
the buildings would appear flat roofed
as a parapet wall would be
would rise to a height of nine meters
obscuring a shallow pitch roof beyond
the buildings would have a simple
rectangular footprint
and the facing material would be
corrugated metal sheeting
on the elevations in a contrasting sort
of dark and then a light
version of that material glazing would
use aluminium frames
um and generally the glazing is to the
front elevation so that's the
the top elevation you can see on the
screen and the side elevations which
would be
which are on the bottom of the screen
the use of the proposed buildings for b1
and b2 of
b1 and b2 and some b8 would accord with
the original outline consent
a correction to the report is noted at
3.16
as the original outline allocate allowed
for a total of a thousand square meters
of b8 use
not for the figure stated the applicant
is aware of the restriction on the
outline with regard to b8 use
which any reserve matters application
consent such as this would have to
comply with
um it's suggested that an informative is
added um just for the interest of
clarity
it is considered that this reserve
matters application provides appropriate
detail
of landscaping scale appearance layout
and access
which are the matters for determination
here and
in relation to the business part context
it is considered that
the application is appropriate therefore
the recommendation is one of approval
subject to conditions two and four being
amended
um as i have just mentioned and also
the reported conditions in the report
um that's it thank you
okay thank you very much um
we have a real life speaker on this one
for the first time uh this is miss kelly
mccann who's the agent
who has five minutes to speak to us and
we'll give it
viewer a reminder up four so
uh over to you thank you great thank you
um good evening members
i'm a senior planner at knight frank and
i'll be speaking on behalf of the
applicant henry boot developments
um as katie has provided a very
comprehensive overview of the proposed
development
i'll just highlight a few key points the
scheme presented this evening has been
informed through discussions with
officers
at rochefort district council and is
recommended for approval
the application constitutes another
phase in the delivery of the overall
master plan for airport business park
south end
outline planning permission as approved
in october 2016
established the principle of
comprehensively redeveloping the site to
deliver a new business park with a range
of uses
including b1 b2 and b8 users
the outline planning permission reflects
the allocation of the site for future
redevelopment within the london south
end airport and environs joint area
action plan
this application follows previous
reserve matters permissions for the ipco
unit
spine road and cost the drive-through
beyond the outline planning permission
and joint area action plan the provision
of
employment floor space and b1 b2 and b8
uses specifically
is strongly encouraged by court strategy
policies ed1 and dm32
the proposed development will provide a
series of flexible industrial units
encompassing
6467 square meters gia
that can be operated under use classes
b1 b2 or b8
the units can be easily and readily
subdivided or amalgamated
to respond to market demand this means
that the units can be operated flexibly
and as per the final operator's
requirements
when completed it's estimated that the
proposed development will
create an additional 137 to 180
full-time jobs
depending on the breakdown of b1 b2 and
v8 floor areas
it should be noted that there have been
no comparable schemes in terms of
quantity or quality of floor space
within the local area over recent years
we're providing a much needed
development with associated benefits in
terms of employment
and business development the buildings
have been designed to accord with the
indicative design principles and
parameters approved under the outlying
permission
the unit will be of a high quality
specification similar to other
speculative industrial schemes that have
been developed by henry boot across the
country
the buildings have been designed so that
they complement surrounding built form
including the ipco unit to the south of
the site and south end's
launch pad scheme to the northwest the
elevations are of a contemporary
aesthetic with simple and clean material
palette
including light and dark grey metal
cladding with glazing to the front
coloured canopies and signage to be
installed at the entrance point to each
unit which will break up the massing of
each terrace and improve legibility
the landscape design is in accordance
with the approved design code which
aimed at creating a strong landscape
corridor along the spine road
we have sought to add as much soft
landscaping as possible into the scheme
the proposed development includes 75 car
parking spaces
including 15 accessible spaces and 54
cycle parking spaces
this accords with maximum car parking
standards set out within essex county
council's parking standards spd
in summary the proposed development is
supported by virtue of the outline
planning commission
allocation within the joint area action
plan and by planning policy which
encourages the development of new
employment spy
spaces for the reasons i have explained
i kind of asked that this application be
approved
thank you very much um
do any of our non-members wish to speak
on this one
okay thank you i'll start with count
slaves
please thank you um just a couple of
uh things to question on this one the
refuse
areas they're obviously designed for
wheelie bins
what happens in the case of a company
that goes in there that has to
operate using normal size skips
i can see this being a bit of a problem
if i could have an answer on that one
please
i'm not sure if there are conditions
that limit uh
that to just the use of the area where
the wheelie bins are designed to go
the other thing is we'll gather we'll
gather up questions in one
one hit at the end yeah
sorry there was one more please chip all
right one more point
um in in light of um the announcement
from central government beginning of
this week
about petrol and diesel cars being
basically not allowed to be sold by 2030
do we have any condition that we can put
on for electric charging points
for cars because i can see that this is
going to become an issue
thank you that's all thank you jim okay
thank you castle wilson
well thank you chairman um my point i
welcome the landscaping um and the
planting
but my question about 3.53 and 3.54
are those um species that are proposed
to be
planted are they native essex
varieties and if they're not is is there
any way that we could have
um suitable native essex species planted
thank you thank you council fd
i'm not going to take up too much time
basically the same point that councilor
eve has made about the electric charging
points
scenes are very short-sighted that
there's none on this
development thank you okay
thank you uh would you like to gather
the questions together please katie
yep fine um taking them in order i think
so
in terms of skips so if i just go
back to sharing the screen
and bring up the site plan so hopefully
you can see the site plan
um on the screen show so actually it
might be better to show
no that's fine so this area here is
proposed for the bin storage
and that clearly is not going to
accommodate um skip
so if there is a requirement for skips
to be used
um if it's a temporary thing then that
could probably be accommodated without
too much of a problem in this kind of in
the area um in front of the building if
it's very temporary
if if any of the potential future users
require um skips to deal with waste in
the future it might mean
the need to re revise um the layout in
front of buildings
um and that would be an application that
would have to
likely come before members to consider
if they need to
cite a skips or permanently in an area
to deal with their waste
and as it stands at the moment the
application
is proposing the service yard the
parking area in this darker
and shading here and then refuse by way
of
bins in these enclosed galvanized steel
structures
um in terms of the petrol and diesel
cars
and the the need in the future for more
electric vehicle charging points it's a
good point
um and we are um
going to sort of insist on the provision
um
for electric vehicle charging points in
the infrastructure to provide those in
future um on applications sort of going
forward
but in this application we're solely
talking about reserve matters
application
so we are limited in what we can take
into account in the determination of
this application
and those matters relate to landscaping
scale
appearance layout and access so that the
the point at which we could um insist on
as a council the provision of certain
infrastructures relating to electric
vehicle charging points is on an outline
application
or a full application so on this
application for reserve matters
um it wouldn't be possible or
appropriate for us to put those
conditions any conditions on
in relation to that it doesn't obviously
it doesn't obviously mean that the
developer couldn't have their own accord
provide some of that infrastructure on
the site
um in relation to the species
um if you bear with me
so i've looked this up myself
so the the trees that i proposed are a
mix of field maple
um italian alder and not not essex
native i want to thought
horn beam crab apple scotch pine cherry
and an ornamental pear so they've got a
variety of species across the site
um they're not all essex native but
there is no
sort of policy requirement for for them
to be
such um so i don't think it would be
appropriate for us to insist on that by
way of condition
but we can certainly raise it as an
informative um for the applicant to
to consider i think that would be the
appropriate way of dealing with that
thank you
and i think that that was
the moment we'll go to council next
sorry thank you chairman um
katie with regard to the um the site
layout
i wonder if you could bring that up
again
thank you um now um
from what you were saying earlier you
said that there was going to be
um a gated entrance to the south
uh entrance
um but there's two access points onto
the site
so is there any reason why it would be
gated only at one entrance or is it
meant to be gated at both entrances
i believe the plan shows gating on both
entrances
mute kate katie
sorry yeah sorry to confirm there's a
gated entrance to both
so on the um eastern boundary the gates
are in set
away from the juncture and bell mouth
and so if you can see my cursor that the
manual
um gateway is approximately here um and
then if i just
scroll around there is another
here so that's the the gated entrance to
the
axis that's opposite path um the
southern boundary
okay uh chairman could i just quick
follow up on that uh
are they um are they meant to be uh
man security gates or is that not part
of the plan
so i i guess
they are for security purposes whether
they'll be manned
or they'll be um some sort of other
control on them i don't know but in
terms of a feature
a kind of gated entrance feature um
there's no concern about the
from an aesthetic point of view the
gates being there and then they're set
um an appropriate distance away from the
bellmouth junction
okay thank you councillor stanley
thank you chairman um
i wasn't uh privy to the to the start of
this
uh as i got disconnected somehow
um there isn't i
i didn't understand are these units
what are these units for the purpose of
first of all and
i noticed that just off cuff uh
there is no no vehicles are allowed on
site then
is that is that correct
so i take that as a question yeah yes
please yeah
um so the units um
all of them are proposed for a
combination i suppose of
b1 so offices and b2 general industrial
and b8
and storage and warehousing uses um
and there's the applicant hasn't been
prescriptive
in the floor space that would relate to
each building
so what it would provide is flexibility
for any future users
but the the use for the bill all of the
buildings for b1
would accord with the outline planning
consent because the intention was for
this um business park
to provide quite a lot of b1 office
accommodation that was
kind of its intention originally the
outline also allowed for
um a certain amount of floor space to be
provided for b2
general industrial um and although there
have been a number of reserve matters
applications on all the little parcels
of the site
the they haven't reached the limit of of
the um
the limit that was imposed on the
outline cond outline application
in terms of the amount of b2 they could
provide
so essentially all of this floor space
could all be b2
general industrial and they are also
asking for an element of it to be b8 so
storage and warehousing
and as i mentioned earlier i'm not sure
if you heard this part but
there was um a limitation on the outline
consent that b8 use across the site as a
whole could not exceed a thousand square
meters
um and obviously if all of this floor
space
were put to b8 that would exceed that
limit but the applicant is aware of the
need for them to comply with the
conditions on the original outline
so it would be a mix of b1 b2 and maybe
some b8
on the site and the answer to my second
question
and your in terms of the parking clearly
there are gates proposed
um they would be opened presumably at
times to let
vehicles in um the site might be closed
as a whole
you know at a certain point in the
evening um and then opened again at a
certain point in the morning
um but it would obviously be available
for people visiting the site to to go in
and kind of um park at suitable times
where would they park could you do could
you tell me where they park and also
um as you said uh that for
uh office use and and uh some light uh
industrial um so where would uh disabled
parkers uh
be able to park should they obviously
they can work just the same as we can so
could you describe to me where they
would park
please yeah so
on this layout what i'm going to do is
just zoom into a certain section but
all of the parking is in this sort of um
pavia you know darker shading where my
cursor is here
so they're the parking spaces and the
white is the service yard so that's the
obviously the entrance into these
parking bays
um and the the larger ones are the
disabled bays
right okay thank you councillor stanley
before we
move on you said you missed part of the
presentation
could you just elaborate on that please
and try and give me a time scale
because that may affect your ability to
vote in this
uh on this application or not um
well i didn't get what the the first
part was about right
six minutes right uh and cancer stanley
the advice is going to be that you're
not able to vote on this
matter i'm afraid um i need to move on
though with other members that have
indicated
my fault is it um counselor fd
uh sorry sorry you've already had one go
dance forever i'll come to council shaw
first
mrs shaw
one for katie katie are we happy with
the
site only having the minimum require
width of vehicles because those vehicles
are getting larger
um they've only gone to the minimum
parking bay dimension
2.5 width and 5.5
sorry 5.5 meters length as opposed to
the preferred
um 2.9 meters by 5.5
is that going to be acceptable for
the cars that are on the road today
please um we'll gather gather up all
questions in one thank you again
um cancer eve she had a second question
second go thank you chair
um my question is a follow-on really
from the answer that katie gave
us on the uh area for refuse
now she was talking about the
possibility if skips were required
because of the nature of the industry
that's actually in there
that they would have a temporary or a
very quick
fix of being able to just dump it and
then load it and get it rid of it
but without conditions i can see that
could be abused
if the obvious place for someone to put
it down would be in parking spaces and a
skip would take up two parking spaces
and the layouts that we've got would
indicate that
the um the adjoining unit would end up
picking up the problem
um now is it possible that we can put a
condition on there
that um refuse um
collection uh items are only to be
put in the refuse area
uh unless a separate application is made
to planning for that to prevent these
kind of problems where i can see
the issue becoming a problem for the
neighbor thank you
cancer fd thank you chairman
so to harp on about this but the
charging points any chance we could get
charging points on as an informative
so ten percent of parking so four
okay thank you thank you council hawkway
thank you chairman um another question
for katie
um uh we've counted these questions
relating to skips has
raised something in my mind um
i know in a number of industrial states
they've
the positioning of containers
like shipping containers uh on site to
allow
uh additional um storage um
is it seems to be allowed on a number of
industrial states
is there anything that would prevent the
uh
a um an occupy of one of the units from
uh
having a uh shipping container uh
permanently placed um outside there in
their unit thank you are there any more
members with questions because we
we we've explored this one quite a lot
so
after these answers are um are passed
over
we will move on with with this
application
so there's no more members indicating so
katie would you like to
bring together the the answers please
yes thank you so councillor mrs shaw
raised the issue of the parking base
being 2.5 by 5 which is the minimum
parking standard which
which is correct those are the the
spaces have been designed to that that
minimum rather than the preferred that
size of space has been
accepted elsewhere on this um wider
business park site so it would be
difficult for us to insist on the
preferred base size for this
in this particular instance um and they
they meet a minimum standard
so um they would be usable
spaces um maybe not for
huge vehicles but for the average
vehicle um
and some vehicles are getting kind of
smaller as well um
they a minimum parking base is is
acceptable here
um in terms of the skips um
what we do have is condition four on the
application
um so condition four requires that all
of the parking bays
be provided and retained in perpetuity
what we could do is just to dot the eyes
and cross the t's is to make it clear
that the service yard area so allowing
the access into those spaces should also
be kept clear so that the service yard
is just
to be used for the maneuvering of
vehicles into and out of parking bays
and into and out of the units so that
that would
um mean that you know a skip
couldn't um or a container which goes on
to the next point
couldn't be cited kind of in a kind of
permanent way to cause um blockage
um of parking bays
oh and sorry there was the last one um
in terms of the electric vehicle
charging point we certainly can put that
that one as an informative um
yeah okay thank you members
um we've had a good and full discussion
on that
could i just ask uh rebecca hurst
if you just would uh care to
confirm my view that counselor stanley
would be
it would be inappropriate him to vote at
this point
apologies chair i was trying to find my
cursor um
yes that that is the case unfortunately
members do need to be present throughout
um the item being presented i think
if it had been fleeting then maybe we
could take a few but i think five to six
minutes it's clear that
um through no fault of his own counselor
stanley wasn't
present um in the meeting for the
presentation and on that basis
um it cannot vote okay then
right uh members we're going to move on
to
the voting now so
just uh just briefly just points of
order
katie raised a matter that um
with regard to the uh not just the
parking area but the area
in front of the parking that the
condition
could be amended to make sure that
this could not be used for other
alternatives that it's kept
clear um so does anyone any of the
conditions katie
need to be amended for you
um to meet your suggestion
before we vote yep
so i think um i've already referred to
condition
two and four needing to be amended just
to make sure that the revised
landscaping scheme is delivered
and that would deliver some tree
planting and hedge planting
um within the kind of parking area of
the site
in addition i'm suggesting that we amend
condition four
also which already requires that the
parking is provided and maintained in
perpetuity
for use solely for parking of vehicles
but also
to add to that condition to say that the
service yard area should be
used solely for the maneuverability of
vehicles
either to access parking bays or to um
drop off you know and access into the
buildings themselves
and for no other purpose so yes that's
what the recommendation includes now
so that's what we've opened on now yes
thank you thank you so we have
reserved matters application um
there are seven uh condition points
on pages 6.1 6.3
there are amendments as stated uh
to conditions two and four and there
were informatives offered
with regard to tree species and electric
car points
first of all can you please raise your
hand
if you wish to have a recorded vote
i see no hands raised for a recorded
vote
right that please raise your blue hand
if you are in favor of the application
it's like bingo this is
okay please take your hands down
council hawkwood that's it please raise
your hand
if you are against
no indications please raise your hand if
you are abstaining
thank you i don't think we need any
numbers but that
that item is clearly approved thank you
item seven land
to the rear of eight st john's road
great wake ring
this is the item that has a small
addendum
again katie is going to present to us on
this one thank you
thank you i'll just share my screen
okay so hopefully members can see a
location plan on screen
this application is to a backland site
accessed off st john's road
residential development borders the site
to all sides the proposals ceased to
demolish the existing buildings that
were previously in commercial use but
have been vacant for some time
and the proposal seeks to construct two
buildings um each containing two flats
so on screen now um is a previously
there is to me just move that slightly
so this is a previously refused plan
because there's quite a lot of
planning history to this site so
this refused application was for five
flats each one bed and converting the
existing buildings
and members refused this scheme back in
2019
but the layout of the refuse scheme
scheme is on screen now
the reasons for refusal related to a
lack of visitor parking provision
and insufficient amenity space to serve
the flats
in the determination of the appeal the
inspector found that the lack of visitor
parking
was not objectionable here um
he did however agree that a minimum 25
square meters of amenity space per
flat should be provided so what the
applicant's done is they've gone away
and in light of that appeal decision
they've amended the pro the proposal
um to the scheme that's before you
tonight so
this now on screen is the proposed
um layout and it's it's very similar
um to the previous one but there are
some differences
so the applicant um
has taken account of the inspector's um
reasoning
um and now has reduced the number of
flats proposed so
whilst previously there were five
there's now four
so the hundred square meters of amenity
space now meets the 25 square meter
provision
and to serve the four flats so that
addresses the and the reason for refusal
or the reason for
the inspectors and dismissing of the
appeal
um four car parking spaces are now
proposed so two
where my cursor is here in an undercroft
it's not a garage it's it's open
to the front and so it's under parking
spaces here
um and two undercroft parking spaces um
to this building
and when my cursor is here
so that parking provision would provide
one space
per flat and all the flats proposed are
one bed
there would still be a lack of visitor
parking um and the 0.25
spaces per dwelling would equate to one
space so
we're looking at a lack of one visitors
parking space on the site
but the lack of visitor parking
provision was accepted previously
on appeal by the inspector and for that
reason
um it is considered that the four spaces
now provided
would be acceptable in relation to the
development proposed
um just take you to the
so on screen now you should see um the
elevation plans
um for plot one so the scale design and
appearance of the building to plot one
is the same as that previously
considered in the previous application
although fenestration is slightly
different
and serving some different rooms um
several conditions are recommended
which would include requiring obscure
glazing
and fixing shut of windows to the side
elevations a slight amendment to the
wording of condition nine is recommended
to include the requirement to obscure
glaze and fixture this south
facing window here as well as the one
um let me just scroll down on the to the
northern side here
and take you to the proposed
elevations to plot two so the change to
the building to plot two
um essentially is relating largely to
the ground floor
which is on the bottom of the screen
here
and the living room has been extended
because previously there were three
parking spaces proposed
um along here and now there's there's
two in this part here
so it's considered members that the
revised proposal has addressed the
reason for the dismissal of the appeal
of the previous scheme by providing
policy compliant amenity space
to serve the four flats proposed and the
recommendation is therefore one of
approval
subject to the stated conditions in the
report and the slight amendment to
condition nine
and to acquire obscure glazing and
fixing shut of the others
of the southern side elevation window to
plot one
thank you very much uh councillor
macpherson as a visiting member i
believe you wish to
speak on this one thank you chairman
um i'd just like to draw the committee
to a couple of points page 7.6
3.15
the inspector acknowledged the local
residents had expressed concern that
this would exacerbate
existing on-street parking demands but
nevertheless
considered that there should would be
existing
on street capacity to accommodate for
the limited number of displaced
vehicles associated with this proposal
the inspector accepted that the area
is more heavily parked at the weekend
but still concluded
that the surrounding streets would be
capable of inappropriately
of appropriately sorry absorbing the
limited additional parking demand
created
by this scheme it was therefore
concluded by the
inspector that the appeal scheme would
have been
unlikely to significantly inconvenience
existing residents through an increased
income petition for
on on street spaces or prejudice
pedestrian or vehicular safety
can i just say i get so very
disappointing when someone who has
absolutely no local knowledge or has at
least taken time
to do research before giving
complete disregard to our development
committee
i would expect someone of such position
to at least
have done some research if they had they
would not
have assumed that there would be
existing
on-street capacity instead they would
have discovered that there is no
capacity
that there is a daily issue with parking
so much so that the most recently
the refuse collection days have had to
be altered
so that a smaller collection vehicle
could be organized for these
roads so as i say it's disappointing
when the inspector makes these decisions
with little knowledge
could i also refer to 3.17 and 3.18
which refer again to parking
these spaces are in carpools which are
as the officer has explained and closed
on three sides
so you will be driving in and reversing
out of these
so i've asked questions whether they
would actually be usable
would drivers be able to vacate their
cars once
parked it is intimated to me by officers
that these are acceptable and that they
are the same size as previously
submitted
it would be good if this could be
confirmed that they are
as the previous plans and the previous
plans were also
enclosed on three sides and exactly the
same format
if then perhaps the committee could ask
this question
also just finally the refuse area
would there be any condition that these
are taken to the perimeter on collection
days
and returned to the refuse area by the
residents as soon as emptied
and not left on the footpath or blocking
the entrance which will cause
more obstructions thank you very much
chairman
thank you council mcpherson councillor
steptoe
as a visiting member you've also
indicated
yes thank you uh chairman um i'd like to
uh uh agree with um most of uh what
uh councillor mcpherson has said with
regards to the parking
it is a daily issue down some johns road
and for those that aren't familiar with
saint john's road uh part of it is
actually an unmade road
and not necessarily part of the adopted
highway
the main issue i wanted to ask the
committee to consider
is the property which is number eight
which is to the east of the um
development um
has an access through the uh the the new
driveway
to the rear of their property would that
be maintained
that needs to be made sure that that
still maintains that access that they
have
already have at that point um
with regards to the size of the
parking parking bays uh yes again
it is becoming more and more uh
difficult with the cuts
design and the shape of cars that once
you go into a parking space such as that
it is very difficult to access the
vehicle
um i certainly find it difficult uh
speaking personally
um actually just needs to the people i
don't know
thank you that's both of our non-members
that have indicated
we'll now move on to the members part of
the discussion
before we um do that members
i must remind you that we have recently
seen an almost identical application
here
which has gone to inspection
the two primary issues that we're
focusing on here
are the visited parking and the immunity
space
it would not be appropriate to be
bringing up
new issues that we have found acceptable
in a recently considered
application and just say that at the
outset
counselor stanley please
thank you chairman um katie could you
just bring up the overall picture
of the the whole unit the whole site
please thank you
um the amenity space that we're talking
about
you say has been increased um
are you including the
dotted line in that commute in that
space or is it from the
if you like the other side of the
parking
one wall under parking
from that to the back is what what
what's the
boundary of the amenity space
and secondly um
when this is gonna it's gonna look very
good
but if you have driven into parking bay
one
how can you can you do a three-point
turn in that shared blocked paved
drive area to drive out
of the of the units
thank you counselor wilson please
thank you chairman um parking it
is is always an issue it's one of the
biggest issues throughout the country
um and i agree with what
i mean i'm not familiar with the area at
all but uh i agree with
the the sentiment of councillor
mcpherson and councillor steptoe
and really we should be designing um
places that work for people work for the
residents
and it's a question really um for katie
that um does the
um inspectors decision their ruling
does that trump our publish policies
thank you counselor mrs shaw
thank you chairman um my issue is i've
got one q i've got a couple questions if
i can
um it is about parking
are the parking spaces shown that we
can on the new plans the same sizes
as the ones that were refused uh
on the last application please and and
i've been reading on 3.5 that the
inspector says it's a village area and
there's plenty of transport public
transport
but i've just looked and the buses run
one every one and a half hours they
start at seven o'clock and finished at 6
45
so these people need and i'm going
i'm not digressing here it is because of
the parking
the people who live here will need cars
to be able to get to a state to the
station
because there will they will not be able
to use public transport
if katie could just ask the question
about the parking spaces for me please
thank you
okay uh councillor fd
thank you chairman i also agree with uh
cancer stepso
councillor mcpherson and councillor shaw
about the parking
um again mckay answers the question
about
the free size the our cars will fit in
now how cars will maneuver will be
interesting
um i also had a maybe a point with the
trees that were overshadowing if we can
put maybe a conditional saints so the
trees
don't go over three meters maybe dwarf
trees or
japanese maples or something like that
which would
hopefully answer one of the uh
letters against this um yeah just look
to
see katie's answers to the questions
thank you okay
councillor eves thank you chair
um to um
i want to express my agreement with
pretty much everyone who's actually said
about the parking issue
i know when we previously went as a
committee
to the site to look at it when it was
the previous application
i had a problem parking down that road
there and i could see that there was an
issue
it was obvious to anyone who went there
so i am really quite
surprised at the comments from the
inspector and i do agree
that there seems to be a lack of um
uh knowledge of the area there in his
judgment
obviously we can't question his judgment
but i do
actually think it's quite naive to think
that this is not this is not going to
actually
create a parking issue the other thing
is um
was the bin store where it is now
marked on the drawing there last time
because if that wasn't there
last time then that is part of this
application and we can comment on that
the reason being why i say that is there
was an application that we had last year
where position of bins on bin collection
day
was part of the issue um and if the
uh bin men have to walk all the way down
the drive there to actually get the bins
from the bin store where it's marked
i would like to suggest that isn't going
to happen um
so i would like to know if there is
any arrangement within the application
to
have an area where the bins can be put
outside without interfering with our
access to adjoining properties
thank you councillor hawkway
thank you chairman um as a wall council
i'm very familiar with this road
um and um i
i understand the concerns raised uh by
other councillors in relation to
um issues to do with parking um
the i think the the fact that there is
no
visitor parking means that any visitors
are likely to try and attempt to park
in the st john's road which is
uh always
full and very difficult to find spaces
so i do believe that
we are meant to look at um the
application and within the red
boundary lines but the the the impact of
this um
particular application is probably going
to be felt
mostly outside of those red boundary
lines
um i do have concerns about um
the layout of the parking within the
plan and
the ability of vehicles to be able to
maneuver
into those parking spaces um
and so you know our vehicle is going to
have enough space to be able to
come into the area uh in
in using forward gears and be able to
move around so they can
access the area and then exit
using forward gears and not have to
reverse down the access
road i'm not sure that
that's been explained sufficiently if
there's sufficient
room for vehicles to be able to maneuver
so that they can then go
out of the uh the access road facing
forwards
thank you thank you councillor mr shaw
thank you chair um my
question is regarding the um
refuse bins the principal street scene
officer has commented
that the flats will require communal
bins
and that should be suitable storage
allowing collection from the curbside
who's going to be responsible for
putting these are obviously going to be
larger bins
who's going to be responsible for
putting these out on the
curbside and withdrawing them at the end
after they've been collected
thank you well we've had
uh seven members make a variety of
points
um i'll come to katy please to
answer the questions
thank you so in order um
the amenity space so it hasn't been
increased
but what has happened is the number of
flats that the area served has been
reduced
so um it's 100 square meters and it's
taken from
if you can see my cursor um so this
point here
um excluding this area here because this
this is part of the um kind of shared
block paved driveway area
um so it excludes that and then curls
around here
and includes the patios to the front so
it's essentially
all of this area where it's labeled
communal garden area
and it excludes all of this shared block
paid drive
area and it including excluding this
kind of little turning
head part of that shared drive
um in terms of vehicles turned within
the site
um the the arrangement of parking spaces
is the same as that was proposed
previously with the only change being
that previously there was an additional
space here you can see where my cursor
is
next to parking bay 4 on the plan on
screen
and that has now been omitted
um then we had a question
about um from councillor wilson about
the
in the weight we'd give to the
inspector's decision
um so it certainly is a material
consideration that has to be taken into
account in the determination of this
application it is relevant
um and in the determination of the
previous appeal
um the inspector had all of the
neighbor objections that were received
in relation to that
application and any
representations that received in
relation to the appeal
they also had the council's appeal
statement which which
set out in more detail members concerns
about parking
in the locality and it included
photographs of evidence of
of parking stress on on saint john's
road
um it also the appeal statement from the
council also
referenced a fairly recent appeal in
hockley
where the inspector there actually
agreed with members
about the impact on existing residents
as a result of increased competition
from on-street parking
um so that was reference in the appeal
and notwithstanding all of that
information
the inspector still concluded in the way
they did
in relation to the um previous
application
on this site um and their previous
application
was insufficient if you like in terms of
our parking standard by two
visitor spaces whereas this application
now is is insufficient
in relation to our standard by one
visitor space because they've reduced
the number of flats
to four so it is a material
consideration that's
the why the recommendation is as it is
um in respect of that issue um
in terms of whether the parking sizes
are the same as previously
um yes they are um so there were two
spaces here
um these are 2.6 meters wide so they
would
accommodate a car and allow um somebody
to
to access um get into and out of that
vehicle
um and in relation to the bin store
area here this was the same area that
was proposed previously
so no issue was taken um in respect of
the location of this bin storage area in
relation to the previous application so
it would be
um unreasonable i would suggest for us
to raise this as a concern now
um it would be for either the residents
um if the refuse collectors aren't
willing to
to go up the driveway to collect from
here to position
a bin for collection and then take it
back
um following uh it being having been
emptied
um and i think
that was all the questions yeah thank
you
um members i don't
whether you agree or not i don't think
we need to remake any
any any points again but cancer stanley
you have indicated
thank you chairman um just to point out
that um
is katie indicating that the
patio areas can be used
by all residents no matter
where they are in that enclosure they
can use
either patio as they so wish the patios
are not relevant for
that particular flat or that particular
property
and also i didn't get an answer as to
how one drives into plot one
car park and how one
reverses and does a three-point turn in
that small area
and the fact of joining the drive in on
plot
two to drive forward as you are driving
forward
or would you you would then have to
drive
reverse but drive out but then you'll be
reversing the car all the way down to
the front
to st john's uh club
thank you for the points made thank you
thank you
uh councillor mr shaw
far final one yeah thank you check this
katie you're saying
oh and we can't really go with the beans
are they they're not the normal sized
bins are they they're going to be bigger
bins so
and they're going to be a lot heavier
for residents to actually
pull out to st john's road um if the
beans
can't afford men can't get into that
this development
is that what we're saying i just want to
clarify on it is the are the bins
in the bin store gonna be what we have
in our normal houses or are they gonna
be a bigger size bin please
come on man yep so um
i haven't got details specifically of
what bins
um would be provided but in
flattered schemes can often have
communal bins
which are larger than the bins that
would be provided to an individual
dwelling um but
in in terms of this storage area and the
um provision of larger bins it's the
scheme is the same as was previously
proposed
so we didn't have a reason for refusal
on the last scheme around this issue of
the bin storage area
so this area can accommodate um refuse
bins for the four
one bed flats um be it um
large bins or the standard bins and that
would be a decision for the
kind of waste team i think to make on
this application
thank you so members i must remind you
again
this application has been considered by
us previously
all of the things were found acceptable
not all liked
but found acceptable with the exception
of visitor parking
and amenity space
an independent inspector has
reconsidered
all of the evidence that we considered
they've found that they don't have an
issue with the visitor parking
on the road whether we like it or not
it's not considered
uh an issue by the inspector after
reconsidering all the evidence
that we've considered the immunity space
is the same as was indicated before but
instead of being shared between five
people
it's now shared between four and
it now meets the standard there's
clearly been indication that there are a
number of other things that people
don't like but we have to remember we're
determining a planning application
on planning matters and those planning
matters
have been visited by us and determined
on
they've been visited by an inspector and
determined on
and they are exceptionally relevant and
material
to the way in which we choose to make
this decision
so um i'd just like to double check that
all members
have heard cancer stanley uh you you've
been fully with us this time around
no other members have indicated that
they've had a problem and not been able
to hear
the information the report
is for recommendation for approval it's
on 12 points
across pages 7.1 to 7.3
with condition 9 regarding glazing
being amended so members
can i ask you please to raise
katie could you take off the share
please just so that it's cl we've got
absolute clarity for voting
purposes thank you could i ask you to
raise your blue hand
if you wish to have a recorded vote
that passes um for for
audit purposes i believe we need to
count those
i've got four which passes the threshold
okay hands down please so there will be
a recorded vote
hands down please
okay right okay all hands are down
please raise your hand if you are in
favor of this
application
four hands down please
all hands down please raise your hand
if you are against this application
i have seven there please drop your
hands
please raise your hand if you wish to
abstain
we have the one
so that item
that item is refused
or not approved so can i
can i just take a little bit of clarity
here
from the way this voting system has
worked the voting
has not allowed us to approve
but effectively we've refused without
reasons
for the refusal do we now need
to move to every to reasons for refusal
the voting has not approved it
now just take a bit of advice there
please
so what we now need
is a substantive motion
from someone uh with regards to the
refusal
as this item has not been approved
councillor hookway
i would state that the reason for
refusal is that
the application doesn't meet
our council's policy in relation to
visitor parking
fd and also parking base sizes
could i just ask katie
to just pass comment on the
items that have been suggested
particularly the parking base eyes
which would be a new addition
thank you yes thank you um
so i think um the difficulty
um members may have is that
this these the first reason for refusal
suggested by councillor hookway
in terms of the application not
providing um
visitor parking in accordance with the
council's parking standard
was essentially word for word the reason
for refusal
on the previous application and an
inspector
has disagreed on that point
and taken of you that um
a parking provision of five spaces to
serve
um five flats would be acceptable
on the previous scheme and actually in
this scheme
we're getting four spaces to serve four
flats
and the visitor parking requirement has
gone down if you like in terms of
the requirements so it has already been
examined on appeal
um and i think there is a potential risk
of costs
being awarded against us um in terms of
putting the same reason forward that's
been um
already you know considered
um in relation to the parking bay sizes
um
that that introduces another uh well it
introduces a reason for refusal that
wasn't
identified in relation to the last
scheme
so again my advice would be the same and
probably
even i'd i'd advise even more caution
against introducing a reason for refusal
that hasn't didn't even feature
previously
um the parking base sizes are no
different in terms of size on this
application
thank you uh uh mr horton you'd like to
come in at this point as well
sorry i think i think um you just asked
the question to casey that i was going
to
ask just my concerns around the validity
of uh
of the reasons for refusal
it feels like groundhog day so an
inspector i'll take it
we'll view it in that way thank you
councillor hookway
you you you you're the one that uh
proposed this you've heard that your
specific reason
was inspect was tested on inspection
and failed that test well
i think i take the view that um
basically
um the previous application provided
zero visitor parking this
application provides zero visitor
parking it doesn't
there's this um it doesn't meet our
policy um
so um
the other thing is is that um
i mean another inspector may take a
different view i'm prepared to
uh because the of the issues i've
unprepared that
uh to let another inspector take a
second view on this matter
we ask um medical people to get
second opinions we might as well have a
second opinion relations this
can i ask if there is another member
that
is happy to second the direction in
which you're traveling
uh cancer stanley your hand was up was
that two
second
yes that was the second and and the fact
that uh
the not only is it inadequate
it it doesn't give reality on how
you would maneuver around that area so
it is to do with parking uh
most understand understandably thank you
okay
thank you so um
councillor hook where you're putting
forward the
the reason for refusal uh of the the
lack of visitor parking
another member mentioned the parking bay
size and you heard the officer's comment
there
could you just like um whether you're
i'm not
i'm not um okay i don't think it's
appropriate for that to be added i'm
only prepared to
put forward in my okay the first item
right
so members i i i believe this is a
a crass mistake and in all the planning
training
uh that i've ever experienced and it's
quite a bit over the years
i'll wholeheartedly agree with officers
to have
a a planning inspector decision that is
so
very very recent to be ignored like this
is
is a huge error that we are making and
i'll i'll go to the
um assistant director who will also
give you another bit of for formal
opinion on this
before we make a determination because
you have to be absolutely aware
about the decision you are about you're
potentially going to vote on thank you
i i mean the only alternative is to to
first seeking a sort of uh
an independent legal view uh on this
aspect just so that
we can perception that's a further
committee
before you consider the actual um
outcome because as you say
that uh it is um unusual to to go
against inspectors ruling
uh for a committee to go against
inspectors ruling and it's also um
then puts us in a position where it's
actually quite hard to defend
uh for officers from a professional
point of view because the professionals
always
has already ruled that this is an
acceptable application
and so in terms of legality i think
there are concerns that perhaps beyond
beyond
our my understanding that i wonder if
it's worth seeking a uh
a further view on before we actually
make a decision that's all i could say
is perhaps answers coming to consider
this fury well if they didn't mind each
other
thank you at the moment we have a motion
put
forward by council hawkway which has
been properly seconded
i don't want to open the debate up much
further
but a number of people are indicating
can you keep your comments please
concise please uh councillor weston
it's a quick question chairman am i
allowed to ask what sort of
figure are we looking at if this goes
further that's that's not
that's not relevant that's right i don't
believe and and
we we need to determine this on
planning matters not what a potential
cost may or may not be
councillor wilson
thank you chairman really it's about
democracy and who rules
we've got we've got published policies
and we're actually being overruled by
the inspector so
i i just think our policies should
prevail
thank you okay thank you council stanley
thank you chairman a decision that's
been made by the development committee
and this decision should stand as it is
it's been seconded it's been put to you
and the decision has not been made yet
on the refusal there is
there is no reason whatsoever that
one can take the view second time around
as to say that the first view
was wrong so that's where it stands okay
okay council williams
thank you chairman yeah just to say that
should council hook away's
uh recommendation fail i would happily
recommend deferment on this fern
thank you thank you that's the hook way
anything fine i'll say before we vote
uh thank you chairman for allowing me to
come back
um no i think um
uh councillor wilson and council stan
lee have
uh put uh the points uh fairly clear so
i'm
happy to stand back behind their words
thank you it's clear it's clear where we
are
you're not going to add anything new
councilman sure no
sorry my hand got taken down i don't
know why why you were talking
i would go with um the assistant
director
and say can we please defer this to take
further legal advice yeah unfortunately
we're at the position where we are
with the motion to be determined now
so we have a motion from councillor
hogway
to refuse this item
based on the lack of
visitor parking all members have clearly
heard the advice and the debate
could i just ask that it be included
that in the wording
that it is against our stated and
written policy
yeah fair enough um
yes those members
wishing to have a recorded vote
please raise your hand
i'm counting that as three
four sorry four
five
okay four please drop your hands
thank you hands cleared those in favor
of supporting councillor hookway's
reason
for refusal please raise your hand
counting five there
thank you if you could drop the hands
okay hands clear those members who are
against supporting councillor hookway's
reason
for refusal
one two three four five
german my hand won't go up
i think that that is a fair indication a
fair positive indication
that's the merrick one plus one two
three four
five making six in total thank you
please drop the hands
okay thank you those members that wish
to abstain
none all right
that item
for refusal is not supported
we're therefore in the no man's land
and i go straight to counselor
williams i'd like to repeat my
proposal that we re deferred this
application
for further um
further information on the matter please
okay councillor mrs shaw
i'd like to second councillor williams
proposal thank you
thank you so we have a motion now put
forward for
a further deferment which is
appropriately seconded
um i think we've had more than enough
debate and all fully understand
the various aspects of this this
discussion
um to go straight to a vote
so we'll go through the same procedure
again
those members in favor of a recorded
vote
please raise your hand one two three
that reaches the threshold again
okay please draw drop the hands
those members in favor of supporting the
deferment
of this item pending further legal
discussion please raise
i'm counting eight
i'm now at nine please
just looking for sonia to nod ahead that
she's got the name
nine nine players
i'm not quite clear what we're are we
voting for or against or
what is it i'm confused now
well we've just done that element please
drop the drop the hands please
i just need to finish off
you tell everybody to drop their hands
all hands are dropped those people
those members that are not in favor of
supporting
the deferment please raise your hand now
we appear to have had an inappropriate
double vote there
cancer stanley your hand was up for and
both to defer and to not defer
chairman i i i got confused there when
you said
in the last vote whether it was before
or ago members
just hold on for clarity i need to rerun
this vote i can't take any chances with
democracy not been clearly demonstrated
we'll move again to vote
on councillor wilson's proposal
to defer this item pending further legal
discussion
which was seconded by councillor shaw
richard
council williams county william sorry
gosh
sorry for that right those members in
favor of a recorded vote
please raise your hand
i have three hands the threshold is
passed please drop your hands
all hands down please raise your hand if
you are in favor
of supporting the deferment pending
further legal discussion
as put forward by councillor williams
one two three seven
that's seven
please drop your hands oh
all hands are dropped no
cancer meric
all hands are down those members who are
not
in favor of supporting the motion for
further
for deferment please raise your hand
that's four
please drop your hands
all hands dropped those members in fa
who wish to abstain please raise your
hand
there are no hands raised therefore that
item shall be further deferred
as per the motion
i believe that that now concludes our
meeting
at 8 55. here
can i ask a question just before you go
uh you can but i i'm going to finish the
meeting though
and uh and we'll stop the live stream
then you'll take i'll take the question
i need legal advice i seem to be the
person
is this within the meeting or without
the meeting it is
do you believe there has been a so it's
a misconduct within the meeting cancer
stanley
well i believe there is yes
right thank you this committee
development committee is supposed to
decide
articles on the development of
developments
are we now proposing
that all developments will now go
to legal to make sure that we are
legally now
entitled to make decisions on the
development committee
i need to know i need to know let me
speak because
you've had plenty of say so i need
something to say now could we do a moot
please sonia
thank you members we've conducted the
business of the meeting
any further business is clearly for
outside of this venue
so i shall close the meeting now at
eight
uh 8 57 thank you
chairman good evening